digamos que tienes una tienda de
pasteles de cereza y has notado que hay
variabilidad en el número de cerezas en
cada pastel que vendes digamos que no sé
a lo mejor te das cuenta que algunos
tienen aproximadamente 100 cerezas otros
tienen menos de 50 cerezas así que
tienes curiosidad de cómo es la
distribución de las cerezas en los
pasteles por ejemplo es interesante
preguntarse cuántos pasteles hay con
pocas cerezas cuántos pasteles tienen
muchas cerezas cuántos pues tienen más o
menos digamos número agradable de
cerezas así que te das a la tarea de
hacer un historia más ok y digamos lo
que haces es tomar cada cada pastel de
la tienda digamos aquí tienes tu pastel
ok
quizás no es la mejor representación de
un pastel de una tienda casera verdad
pero bueno digamos que aquí tienes tu
pastel y entonces tomas las cerezas y
las empiezas a contar digamos las que
están arriba muy bien
y tienes las cerezas ok y digamos que no
sé a lo mejor te da 32 cerezas muy bien
entonces el punto después de hacer todos
estos conteos con todos los pasteles de
la tienda de la tienda perdón es
acomodar toda la información en cubetas
digamos de 30 en 30 muy bien no sé por
ejemplo podría ser la primera cubeta que
tenga entre 0 y 29 cerezas ok de hecho
aquí se ve en el histograma que no hay
pasteles con tan poquitas cerezas pero
sí hay pasteles que tienen entre 30 y 59
cerezas entre 60 y 89 entre 8 perdón 90
y 119 y entre 120 y 149 por supuesto
esta cubeta es más pequeña porque a lo
mejor tú ya sabes que no hay pasteles
con más de 150 cerezas muy bien entonces
digamos que de esta forma uno empieza a
construir el histograma verdad uno
empieza a ver por ejemplo que hay 5
y pasteles de que tienen entre 30 y 59
cerezas
además también te das cuenta que hay 8
pasteles vamos a hacer lo mejor con
con blanco muy bien digamos que tenemos
5 aquí aquí podemos observar que hay 8
pasteles que tienen entre 60 y 89
cerezas hay 4 pasteles entre que tienen
entre 90 y 119 y hay 3 pasteles que
tienen entre 120 y 149 entonces así es
cómo has construido ya tu programa
ahora el objetivo es interpretar toda
esta información que ya está plasmada en
esta representación gráfica ok entonces
el punto de hacer la interpretación es
poder resolver algunas preguntas que
pudieran surgir nos de esta desde todos
estos datos por ejemplo podríamos
determinar el número total de pasteles
que hay en la tienda entonces yo te
invito a que hagas una breve pausa y
trates de resolver este problema por tu
propia cuenta y ahorita lo hacemos
juntos
ok entonces suponiendo que ya fue tiempo
suficiente para poder sacarlo pues vamos
a ver cuántos pasteles tenemos en esta
tienda bueno sabemos que hay cinco en
esta cubeta 8 en esta cubeta 4 en esta
cubeta y 3 en esta cubeta entonces si
queremos saber el número total de
pasteles lo único que tenemos que hacer
es sumar todos estos números verdad
entonces tenemos 5 en la primera cubeta
8 en la segunda 4 en la cubeta verde y 3
en la cubeta amarilla entonces si
sumamos todo esto nos da 5 + 8 estos son
13 + 4 son 17 + 3 esto nos da un total
de 20 pasteles en la tienda muy bien
vamos a tratar de responder alguna otra
pregunta por ejemplo cuántos pasteles
tenemos con al menos 60 cerezas ok vamos
a saber cuál es el número de pasteles
número de pasteles con
al menos al menos 60 cerezas muy bien es
decir a lo mejor ese es nuestro número
adecuado de cerezas que debe llevar un
pastel verdad entonces habría que ver
cuántos tenemos entonces podríamos
observar que sería contar todo lo que
está a partir de la barra azul verdad
aquí tenemos 60 89 luego 90 119 luego
120 149 entonces lo único que tenemos
que hacer es considerar todos excepto la
primera verdad es decir tener 84 más
tres verdad entonces esto que nos da 8
más 4 son 12 más 3 son 15 lo cual está
bien verdad porque era el total de
pasteles excepto la primera barra que
eran 5 entonces si el total eran 20 y no
consideramos la primera nos debe dar
justamente 15 verdad y así podríamos
seguir respondiendo preguntas
interesantes por ejemplo otra que se me
ocurre es cuántos pasteles hay demás qué
entre 60 y 89 cerezas con respecto a 120
bueno pasteles que tienen entre 120 y
149 cerezas ok entonces por ejemplo si
quisiéramos responder eso aquí sabemos
que tenemos 8 pasteles mientras que aquí
tenemos 3 así que la diferencia entre
estas dos categorías es justamente 5 muy
bien y así hay un montón de preguntas
que podríamos tratar de responder así
que espero que este vídeo te haya
ayudado a ver cómo interpretar
histogramas